it is great to welcome to the program
today Phil Gorski who's a 30 year
Canadian intelligence veteran author of
five books on terrorism and also host of
the podcast an intelligent look at
terrorism Phil it's great to have you on
today hey it's great to be here David
thanks for inviting me on the show
so I mean where to start right I guess
the the war on terror has now been waged
for decades uh how is it going are we
winning it yet no we're not and you know
you referenced the fact that I've
written five books my fourth book was
actually entitled an end to the war on
terrorism I hate the term I've hated it
since day one as you noted in your
introduction I worked in security
intelligence for that so for the
Canadian Security Intelligence Service
kind of an FBI CIA hybrid we looked at
home grown plants Canadians traveling to
join al-qaeda later Isis etc al-shabaab
in Somalia and yet we're framing us
through the military and the problem is
as a American academic said very wisely
after 9/11 he says whatever you do don't
declare war on a common now because it
never ends think of the war on drugs in
your country think on the war on poverty
think on the war on any common now
because you said common nouns don't
surrender whereas proper nouns do so you
ask me how is it going it's going well
and not so well well in a sense that in
your country in mine we're not seeing
terrorist attacks on a regular basis
let's face it that's that that's true
and yet if you look at the news on any
given day David which I do as a regular
course you've know I'm retired I'm still
involved in this business every day in
Afghanistan Somalia or Nigeria or Iraq
or Syria there's an attack and in
several cases many attacks per gate in
those countries so it's going both well
and not so well depending on your
perspective I guess here in the United
States there is an interesting report
from the anti-defamation league which I
referenced before which looked at a
politically based domestic terror
killings so to speak and they are
overwhelmingly right-wing the numbers as
I recall I think in 2019 were 76%
right-wing 20 percent Islamic extremism
and
4% left or sort of miscellaneous now
from a logistical perspective when I
hear that someone believes their
religion should be the law of the land
and is willing to kill for those reasons
to me that sounds right wing's so when I
think of Islamic extremism it's often
framed as left-wing it sounds really
right-wing to me in the intelligence
community is there a position on that on
the characterization of Islamic violence
wow I've never thought of it in that
term before we certainly looked at is
the most extremism as our number one
threat we had several plots in the 2000s
in the 2010s several hundred Canadians
went to join Isis etc etc we had a small
right-wing desk which frankly wasn't
very busy when I retired in 2015 I'm
sure it's busier right now I would push
back a little bit of those stats it's
true that in your country obviously the
far right is about two-thirds or
three-quarters of the incidents yeah
around the world is still 95 percent
isn't as extremism if you look at the
numbers across the world no denial
whatsoever yeah yeah the way you framed
it is really interesting so I did write
a book my last book was entitled when
religions kill and I looked at how every
religion has within it an extreme
element that justifies killing in the
name of God Judaism Christianity even
Buddhism by gaudí Buddhist extremists
should be an oxymoron and yet there are
Buddhist terrorists in Sri Lanka in
Thailand and Myanmar I guess you would
say that is the most extremist are
conservative they're definitely very
intolerant the view of Islam that they
try to force on people is exclusionary
essentially it's my way or the highway
bernard lewis the american academic
academic said very famously after 9/11
it's like as I'm right you're wrong go
to hell that's the way these people see
the world so I guess from that
perspective we would look at it as
right-wing but from my experience
working in the Canadian intelligence
community it was his own separate task
and it was the lion's share of the
counterterrorism work for the better
part of the 20 years you just referred
to in the post 9/11 period when we think
about the radicalization of individuals
when I've interviewed domestic
extremists in the United States like
former KKK and white nationalists and
others almost exclusively there's a
story of there was a lack of empathy
and support in their lives which led
them vulnerable to sort of join up with
whoever paid them attention and accept
the orthodoxy that they presented in an
international terror and the work that
you did
is it a similar pattern what leads to
the radicalization of an individual Wow
how much time do we have I mean my very
first book the threat from within looked
at that and I was basing on kick cases I
worked in Canada unclassified
information obviously but we found the
opposite David we found that these
people were run-of-the-mill average
Canadians they were average from a
socioeconomic status they were average
from an educational background they were
average from a family background they
were average in so far as we could tell
we're not psychologists from a mental
health perspective there was nothing
that sort of divided them or separated
them from the general Canadian populace
and I've seen the same stats for the
United States as well in terms of
Islamist extremism I do think that we
look at the far-right KKK you know the
Boogaloo boys you might see that kind of
a bit of a tendency towards the
down-and-out in life you know you often
hear the term marginalized you hear the
term not making ends meet you know
failing in education failing at
relationships failing at that work
you'll see none of the ism aside but of
course you have exceptions you look at a
country like France yeah and a lot of
the people who joined Isis and al-qaida
in France are on the lower socioeconomic
spectrum but I would argue you look at
French Muslim society in general and
it's generally speaking it's on the
lower you know your country my country
are very different Muslims in our
country have time to tend to do very
very well they tend to be highly
educated they tend to be have good jobs
solid families etc in Europe that's not
the case for all kinds of historical
reasons bottom line David is that
there's no profile to any of this and
people that try to profile get into
trouble because we do try to profile you
run into two problems yes
well one's what I call a false positive
if you think that all jihadis are all
right when guys are X and somebody's is
X and is not a jihadi that's a problem
and then if you say that no jihadi czar
well educated or no KK care well
educated the first guy with a PhD you
don't look at because he doesn't fit
your profile so when we worked at when I
worked for the Canadian Security
Intelligence Service we didn't have a
profile
we looked at activity we looked at you
know online statements which we had
warrants to intercept we looked at what
they said in what they did not who they
were where they came from or what their
particular circumstances were and I
think that was a that was successful for
us when it comes to the leaders of
terrorist organizations over the last 20
years we've all seen endless headlines
of the number two was killed the number
three you know whatever how how
important is that to actually fighting
terror and I'll make the question sort
of a two-part question one if what we're
fighting is an ideology is the ideology
affected by killing an individual is it
sometimes sometimes yes sometimes no
okay and then number two even from the
operational standpoint how effective is
it to kill the number one the number two
the number three guy I can give you an
answer you're not going to like it
depends okay so so in some groups it's
all about the leader they could a group
like Shining Path the sedona Luminoso in
Peru when Guzman was taken by the
Peruvians back in the early 90s the
group never really recovered they're
still around but they're a shadow them
other former selves you look at al-qaeda
bin Laden's gone now Ayman al-zawahri he
can't hold a candle a bit Laden from a
charismatic perspective he's the he's
like watching paint dry and al Qaeda is
still around
we got Baghdady right a couple years ago
you guys got back daddy
Isis is just as strong if not stronger
than it ever was I better cases maybe
the PKK in Turkey the Kurdish militant
group the Turks count captured abdullah
al july back in 1994 he's been in prison
on an island in turkey for the better
part of over 20 years the cake the PKK
is carrying out attacks on a weekly
basis in eastern Turkey so the the the
the short answer is it depends on the
nature of the group and the controller
which the leader has against within that
group the second part of your question
is look it's never a bad thing to take
out a major terrorist we always used to
say a dead terrorist is a good terrorist
you don't have to investigate them
anymore you don't have worry about him
he can't exert his influence etc etc now
we can argue about rule of law and
whether or not extraterritorial
assassinations are legal that's a whole
other discussion
so taking guys out is never a bad thing
the problem is it rarely if ever means
the end it and I'm tired of reading
headlines you know we
got soul and soul this is the end of
group number X X Y or Z it never is or
very rarely is because as you mentioned
is the ideology that's poor important
not the individual the individual can be
charismatic attract people retain people
inspire people
but charismatic people or sometimes a
dime-a-dozen is the ideology that
matters that's what you have to
undermine and that's a lot more
difficult than care you can't carry a
drone strike against an ideology
unfortunately I want to get back to that
but because you mentioned you know the
question as to the legality of
extraterritorial killings of suspected
terrorists in the work you did did that
play at all in in your work or is that
sort of like that was handled that the
legal questions were are handled
somewhere else absolutely so we were
essentially a domestic intelligence
service but we had an international
remit because Canadians were fighting
with the Taliban and all kind of things
like that
we had lawyers obviously that you were
able to guide us but we follow the law
in a sense that we went to court to get
warrants to intercept people's
communications you have to do that he's
can't you know follow somebody up you
know on Twitter or intercept it because
that's the illegal in Canada so from our
perspective we provided intelligence and
you provide it to decision-makers now
sometimes the decision-makers might be
in the Canadian military or the US
military and they will decide to do
without intelligence whatever that their
mandate says that they can do
I didn't lose sleep at night personally
about my intelligence being used in a
way that I might not necessarily agree
with from my own ethical perspective
because first of all a can is a pretty
small player right we're not carrying
out drone strikes that you guys are in
Yemen and Afghanistan and and and
Somalia so in that perspective it wasn't
as important I do think there's a bigger
conversation around this and I know what
that when a neural al Awlaki who was the
American who was killed in Yemen a
couple years ago that raised a real
kerfuffle at your country because he was
an American citizen and didn't get his
day in court right he was yesil to to
refute the charges against him I didn't
lose sleep over Allah key because he was
a major instigator he was a major
charismatic leader of al-qaeda in the
Arabian Peninsula there wasn't a single
Canadian that didn't follow his writings
or his videos online so him disappearing
was it was a good good news day for us
but on the other side of the coin I do
understand the legal ramifications of it
but when you work in intelligence you
provide the best information you can to
those that can use it
and you do so to the best of your
ability okay so now that that being kind
of framed in terms of your work when we
think about what does work to root out
an ideology I mean is it one one area
that doesn't seem to be discussed enough
is sort of the economic situation in the
source countries and when we talk about
undocumented immigration here in the
United States you know the current
administration talks about walls and
they talk about you know jail and all
this stuff if the economic circumstances
were better in the source countries the
demand for trying to come to the United
States illegally would would decrease
dramatically can does that apply to
thinking about the ideologies that rise
and the way in which people can be
indoctrinated can that be separated from
the context in which these countries are
existing yeah you're asking the tough
questions for me on Canada Day ah that's
a tough one again it depends because if
you look at 9/11 for example 15 of the
19 hijackers that attacked New York and
Washington were rich Saudi individuals
they don't have any socio-economic
problems I do think that it obviously
makes sense from a humanitarian and
global stability perspective to make
sure that every country is as
economically feasible and and workable
as possible and yes it might in fact
prevent or convince people to stay at
home rather than come to Canada United
States I mean you know we taking 1% of
our population every year by immigration
we did get 300,000 people a year so it's
it's 1% your country has a similar high
rate I mean it did under the current
president maybe not so much so I think
that put it this way David it can't hurt
but I'm not necessarily certain that it
would be enough to undermine the
ideology the ideology has to be
undermined by the vast majority of
people who live in that greater polity
be it Islam or Buddhism or Hindus and
for Judaism whatever who fight against
it who say this is not what we represent
this is not what our faith tells us to
do this is not what the founders of our
religion said is a good thing to do it's
only those people that can say this is
wrong we're not gonna support it and
we're gonna actively undermine what
you're trying to do that to me and I've
seen it happen here in Canada on a
limited scale that to me is the only way
we're gonna say you
the Islamist extremist ideology or the
Hindu extremist ideology in India which
is very worrisome by the way these days
what Modi is doing with his support from
very violent Hindu extremists in the RSS
and other parts of Indian society those
the people that have to stand up with
our support and basically talk down and
and and get rid of the ideology that is
being spewed by a very small minority
within their communities that's not
let's not exaggerate this right very
very few people espouse this ideology
that's why I mean that's why when I hear
you saying it has to be made clear by
everybody else that this is not
acceptable
it seems that that's already sort of the
case right I mean I guess I would what
you're saying sounds so intuitive and
yet it starts to sound sort of like you
know where where are all of the moderate
Muslims denouncing this and it's like
well they they are right I mean it's so
it starts to get into sort of dicey
territory because you're already talking
about such a small portion of the
population well I would also counter
that you're not gonna get rid of his
ideology it's not gonna disappear
tomorrow I mean communism which we
fought against I started my career in
the Cold War in 1983
there's also Viet unionists over you in
that that found it and yet look what's
happening now in modern Russia you could
argue it's a resurgence of the Communist
ideal or whatever you want to call it so
the ideology is not gonna you know
vanish poof one day into the ether it's
always going to be there what you're
trying to do is to make it such that
it's an irritant not an all-encompassing
sort of I don't know that this obsession
you have it's all terrorism all the time
but it's you know it's not all terrorism
all the time in my country and I'm
actually researching a book on the
history of terrorism of Canada from
Confederation which is 153 years ago
today you know we've suffered at most 20
attacks in 153 years now mind you we
went a century between attack one an
attack two we get my point right we're
not Afghanistan we're not Somalia
we're not Nigeria we're not Yemen that
is it neither is your country neither in
most countries in Western Europe so how
can we get away from this obsession
about terrorism let our counterterrorism
agencies do their jobs as well as law
enforcement get citizenry involved to
talk these guys down to to either ignore
them or to counter their views but let's
not think of that
we're over subtly existentially
threatened by terrorists this is not
make essential threat David it
if you're if you're for an Afghan it's
not if you're an American and it's not
if you're a Canadian we've been speaking
with Phil Gorski who's a 30-plus year
Canadian intelligence veteran author of
five books on terrorism also hosts the
podcast an intelligent look at terrorism
Phil I so appreciate your time today
my pleasure Davis maybe we do this again
sometime